لاول مره منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي
نتمكن من الوصول الى معبر ايرز او بيت
حنون الواقع في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع
غزه هذا المعبر الذي كان احد اهم المعابر
الذي يدخل منها ويخرج منها الفلسطينيون من
داخل قطاع غزه او يدخل من خلاله
الفلسطينيون ابناء الضفه الغربيه المحتله
بطبيعه الحال هذا المعبر مغلق الان والجيش
الاسرائيلي يحافظ على وجود عسكري كبير على
هذا الحاجز ناقلات الجند موجوده الجنود
موجودون هنا بكثافه وكذلك القتال على اشده
ما زال في منطقه بيت لاهيه وفي منطقه بيت
حنون الجيش الاسرائيلي اغلق هذا المعبر
منذ اليوم الاول للحرب حيث كانت كتائب
القسام قد تمكنت من السيطره على قياده
الارتباط في هذه المنطقه وكان واضحا حجم
ال مار الكبير الذي خلفه هجوم السابع من
اكتوبر في هذه القياده هذا المعبر كان
مخصصا لدخول وخروج العمال
الفلسطينيين الى اسرائيل للعمل وكذلك دخول
المؤسسات الدوليه لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي
تعمد في الايام والاسابيع الماضيه الى
تجريف هذه المنطقه هذا الطريق الذي كان
يستخدم
لدخول ال السيارات الى داخل معبر ايرز حل
به ضمار كبير وتم تجريف كل الشارع المؤدي
الى داخل هذا المعبر الهام والرئيسي وكما
اشرنا بان الجيش الاسرائيلي مازال يحافظ
على وجود عسكري كبير في هذه المنطقه لياس
كرام الجزيره من معبر ايرز بيت حنون شمال
قطاع غزه